prasad assez la vieille place du coeur
de san paolo face à la cathédrale
un grand panneau sur lequel est écrit
peu de corrompus en prison 213 millions
de brésiliens condamné en fait c'est un
miroir dans lequel chacun se voit et
doit se demander
suis-je une des victimes de la
corruption par manque de soins de santé
d'éducation d'emploi d'avenir précise la
pancarte alors votez intelligemment tout
près au pied de la cathédrale
les plus démunis des pauvres de ce pays
très inégalitaire les sans abri
dépendent de bénévoles pour la soupe
populaire
mais la corruption est un immense
problème dit cet homme nous sommes
richissime au brésil une richesse
naturelle
nous sommes riches mais toute cette
richesse ce sont les corrompus qu'ils
apprennent aussi encore plus lula est
maintenant en prison
l'ancien président luiz inacio lula da
silva a été condamné à une peine de 12
ans pour corruption
il est le plus célèbre des 123 individu
condamné pour corruption politiciens
hommes d'affaires intermédiaires véreux
qui ont pillé les coffres de la
petrobras la compagnie pétrolière
nationale
un système perfectionné à des fins
politiques par lula et son éminence
grise
josé dire c'est au lui aussi condamné à
31 ans de prison et au réseau via
doussain cause de cet homme qui il y a
deux ans débarqué au canada dans un
petit hôtel du centre de montréal après
avoir essayé de se réfugier aux états
unis au portugal hermès magnus nous
révèle alors que c'est lui qui le
premier dénoncé deux hommes
alberto youssef et le député josé jeanne
est née s'est associé au brésil il se
rend compte qu'ils blanchissent est de
l'argent se servant de sa compagnie il
les dénonce au juge sergio moreau qui
six ans plus tard découvre le lien entre
youssef et le patron la petrobras par
l'eau roberto costa menacé de prison les
deux hommes parlent et dénonce des
dizaines de complices de l'immense
détournement de fonds par le biais de
contrats truqués avec des compagnies de
construction
hermès magnus vit maintenant à
shawinigan il parle français et il a
obtenu le statut de réfugié l'est à tout
ap après huit mois
dans sa décision la commissaire à
l'immigration de nara masieri écrit
compte tenu de l'ampleur du système de
détournement de fonds des acteurs qui
ont été inculpées dans cette affaire de
la présence de la mafia brésilienne
parmi ces inculpés que ces personnes
pourraient mettre votre vie en danger
en conséquence j'accepte votre demande
d'asile tout était corrompu tout tout
tout tout même aujourdh'ui du
aujourd'hui gp10 et avec conviction qui
tout du passo voisine c'est grâce à
l'ajout du jeu à 1 morrow ce que le juge
moreau et son enquête lavage à taux ont
démantelé c'est le plus grand scandale
de corruption de l'histoire du brésil
et peut-être du monde à travailler
une gigantesque affaire policière et
judiciaire que netflix a mis à l'écran
sous le titre au mécanisme le mécanisme
tout le monde au brésil à regarder ça
hermès magnus aussi et il confirme que
même romance et aux mécanismes aux
reflets en très grande partie la réalité
forest hills touche son personnage n'est
pas dans la série télévisée
mais on y trouve le policier fédéral à
qui il a parlé en premier et qui l'a
mise en contact avec le juge sergio
moreau à qui il a dénoncé les associés
qui se servait de sa compagnie pour
blanchir de l'argent douteux bras
alberto youssef se nomme ibrahim dans la
série c'est lui qui distribue l'argent
détourné par le patron petrobras la
compagnie d'état avec la bénédiction du
président du brésil et de celle qui lui
a succédé
l'ex-président lula n'a pas aimé il
poursuit netflix pour diffamation les
sondages le donnaient gagnant aux
élections d'octobre
s'il n'avait été emprisonnés maintenant
les brésiliens sont déboussolés ils ont
perdu toute confiance dans leurs
politiciens trop souvent corrompus le
seul candidat solidement campagne c'est
cet homme
le député indépendant jaillir ball sonar
aux anciens militaires
nostalgique de la dictature à
l'assemblée nationale en 2015 lors de la
destitution de la présidente dilma
rousseff victimes de torture sous la
dictature
il dédie son vote à son tortionnaire et
l'urd est raciste et les chinois fu bo
c'est une personne détestable racistes
et xénophobes et macheist toutes les
qualités qu'on recherche chez quelqu'un
ils les ignorent les méprise les
qualités attendues d'un citoyen il les
méprise et les exècre les ospreys la
corruption d'abord et après la violence
à les combats à la violence seront à mon
avis les deux thèmes des élections
brésiliennes et je pense que ça va
donner un avantage très important à un
bon son héros parce que lui et il a des
réponses faciles à ces deux problèmes
ça va être dans tous les débats jaillir
ball sonar oh bien sûr raffolent de
l'opération lavage est hop la corruption
c'est son cheval de bataille
c'est un bonne solution embrasé je sais
qu'en pense à eux mêmes et amis ont
d'énormes vous êtes fous c'est l'unique
option no brasil non c'est pas ça c'est
pas vrai c'est juste ont vanté
protestent parce qu'il est trop proche
de mêlée kermesse magnus ne pourra pas
retourner au brésil pour voter il y est
encore menacé il vient de recevoir la
moitié du million et demi de dollars que
le juge sergio mro lui a lui même
attribué gérer son indemnisation
l'argent récupéré servira à remplacer le
matériel volé dans son entreprise
d'appareils de vérification de normes
industrielles au brésil il y a dix ans à
présent il attend son statut de résident
permanent au canada et six au canada
je pense que kilian sécurité
dia confiance autorités et tous les
affaires marchent bien comment ça
commence comme en politique
hermes magnus est bien installée à
shawinigan il y est pour rester